so in the last video I introduced the
vector form of the multivariable chain
rule and just to remind ourselves I'm
saying you have some kind of function f
and in this case I said it comes from a
100 dimensional space so you might
imagine well I can't imagine a 100
dimensional space but in principle
you're just thinking of some area that's
100 dimensions it could be 2 if you
wanted to think more concretely two
dimensions and it's a it's a scalar
valued function so it just outputs to a
number line some kind of number line but
I'll think of as f as its output and
what we're going to do is we compose it
with a vector valued function so some
function that takes in a single number T
and then outputs into that super high
dimensional space so you're thinking you
go from the single variable T to some
very high dimensional space that we
think of as full of vectors and then you
take from that over to a single single
variable over to a number and you know
the way you'd write that out is you'd
say F composed with the output of V so F
composed with V of T and what we're
interested in doing is taking its
derivative so the derivative of that
composition is and I told you and we
kind of walk through where this come
from the gradient of F evaluated at V of
T evaluated at your original output dot
product with the derivative of V the
vectorize derivative and what that means
you know for V you're just taking the
derivative of every component so when
you take this and you take the
derivative with respect to T all that
means is that each component you're
taking the derivative of it the x1 DT DX
2 DT on and on until D and then the
100th component DT so this was the
vectorized form of the multivariable
chain rule and what I want to do here is
show how this looks a lot like a
directional derivative and if you
haven't watched the video on the
directional derivative maybe go back
take a look kind of remind yourself but
in principle you say if you're in the
input space of F and you nudge yourself
along some kind of vector V and maybe
just because
using V there L instead say some kind of
vector W so not a function just a vector
and you're wondering hey how much does
that result in a change to the output of
F that's answered by the directional
derivative and you write directional
derivative in the direction of W of F
the directional derivative of F and I
should say at some point some input
point P for that input point and it's a
vector in this case like a 100
dimensional vector and the way you
evaluate it is you take the gradient of
F this is why we use the nabla notation
in the first place it's an indicative
have we computed the gradient of F
evaluated at that same input point same
input vector P so here just to be clear
you'd be thinking of whatever vector to
your input point that's P but then the
nudge the nudge away from that input
point is W and you take the dot product
between that and the vector itself the
vector that represents your nudge
direction but that looks a lot like the
multivariable chain rule up here except
instead of W you're taking the
derivative the vector valued derivative
of V so this whole thing you could say
is the directional derivative in the
direction of the derivative of T and
that's kind of confusing directional
derivative in the direction of a
derivative of F and at what point are
you taking this at what point are you
taking this directional derivative
well it's wherever the output of V is so
this is very compact it's saying quite a
bit here but a way that you could be
thinking about this is V of T I'm going
to kind of erase here V of T as you
zooming all about and as you shift T it
kind of moves you through this space in
some way and each one of these output
points here represents the vector V of T
at some point the derivative of that
what is this derivative represent that's
the tangent vector to that motion you
know so you're zipping about through
that space the tangent vector to your
motion that's how we interpret V Prime
of T the derivative of V with respect to
T and why should that make sense why
should the directional derivative in the
direction of V prime of T this change to
the the intermediary function V have
anything to do with the multivariable
chain rule well remember what we're
asking when we say D DT of this
composition is we're saying we take a
tiny nudge to T so that tiny change here
in the value T and we're wondering what
change that results in after the
composition well at a given point that
tiny nudge in T causes a change in the
direction of V prime of T that's kind of
the whole meaning of this vector valued
derivative you change we change T by a
little bit and that's going to tell you
how you move in the output space but
then you say okay so I've moved a little
bit in this intermediary hundred
dimensional space how does that
influence the output of F based on the
behavior of just the multivariable
function f well that's what the
directional derivative is asking it says
you take a nudge in the direction of
some vector in this case I wrote V prime
of T over here more generally you could
say any vector W you take a nudge in
that direction and more importantly you
know the size of the prime of T matters
here if you're moving really quickly you
would expect that change to be larger so
the fact that the prime of T would be
larger is helpful and the directional
derivative is telling you the size of
the change in F as a ratio of the
proportion of that directional vector
that you went along you could you know
another notation for the directional
derivative is to say partial F and then
partial whatever that vector is
basically saying you take a size of that
nudge along that vector as a proportion
of the vector itself and then you
consider the change to the output and
you're taking the ratio so I think this
is a very beautiful way of understanding
the the multivariable chain rule because
it gives this image of you know you're
thinking of V of T and you're thinking
of zipping along in some way and the
direction and value of your velocity as
you zip along is what determines the
change in the output of the function f
so hopefully that helps give a better
understanding both of the directional
derivative end of the multivariable
chain rule wants one of those one of
those nice little interpretations